so most of us have at this point in our
lives have probably used a chat bot
maybe without even knowing it
have you ever wondered how does a chat
bot work what power is it
how do i interact with it let's dive in
my name is morgan carroll with ibm cloud
let's say you're the owner of a flower
shop
this is you and you're the only
employee maybe you don't have time to
respond to common customer inquiries
such as
what time do you open do you have yellow
roses in stock
how do i contact you so you've got your
customer up here
and they need to get in touch with you
but you're busy you can't answer the
phone
so what can we do to solve this problem
this is where flora the floral chat bot
comes in
this is flora over here now if a
customer has
a simple question let's say they just
want to know um
what time do you guys open they can ask
flora
hey what time do you all open and then
flora is going to be able to respond
with the appropriate answer she's going
to say you know maybe we open
monday at 9 00 a.m all without me having
to interact with the chatbot or the
customer
so that i'm free to do what i love to do
which is
designing floral arrangements now let's
think of a more complex example
say you have the bank here
and you as the customer you would like
to check and see
what your balance is so i just got paid
i don't know how much money is in the
bank but i need to go buy
some socks so rather than having to call
the bank
and wait on hold and wait for a teller
to pull up your information
and check your account status you could
actually interact with
birdie the banking bot
so in this case i'm going to ask birdie
birdie
what is my balance how much money do i
have currently
bertie's going to come back and ask i
can help you with that
but what is your account number
your pin number um you know some
identifying information
so i'm going to be able to provide this
information back to birdie
my account number maybe my date of birth
a pin
number etc etc from there
all without any tellers or any employees
having to interact with birdie
she's going to be able to go and ask the
bank she's going to pass along all this
information my account number
my date of birth and my pin number and
she's going to say hey bank
how much money does this person have in
their account the bank is going to
authorize me and say okay this is all
the appropriate information that we need
the bank is going to respond with i'm
sorry you only have five dollars
maybe enough for socks maybe not but
then
birdie is going to be able to take that
response and pass it back
to me the customer all without having to
interact with any humans
and it's very simple so how does this
really work let's
dive in going back to the floral shop
example let's say tomorrow is mother's
day
and you forgot to order flowers like we
normally do
um so here's you my customer
now like we mentioned before the floral
shop owner is very busy she's putting
together all these arrangements she
doesn't really have time to answer the
phone
so luckily there are a few different
ways that you the user can interact with
our chat bot to actually automate
ordering some flowers for your mother
so on the floral shop website
there could be a little pop-up maybe at
the bottom that has flora
this is flora the floral bot and she's
here and she's going to be able to pop
up and ask me what kind of flowers would
you like to order
obviously yellow roses because those are
my mother's favorite
if we don't want to use the website we
could actually just call in
so it can be either text based or voice
based
so if i call the chat bot she says
welcome to
flower supply 101 what would you like to
place your order for
i would say i would like a dozen yellow
roses and it's just conversational and
she's going to take my
order and be able to process it and you
can also use various instant messaging
services you know for different social
media platforms you can integrate
so you have all these different ways
that you can interact with the chatbot
now let's think about how that actually
works sort of on the back end
so i think by now we're all familiar
with the cloud
it's the buzzword of the year this is
actually where our chat bot is going to
live
so you'll have a chat bot service
provider and this chatbot is going to
integrate with
various services to actually process
whatever speech
it is that the user is saying it's going
to use natural language processing
as well as artificial intelligence to
take what i'm saying
and then actually translate it into
something that a computer can understand
so i'm saying whether it's via phone or
via instant messenger
or to the webpage via text or voice i
would like to purchase
some yellow roses so i'll say purchase
yellow roses and maybe i want to do a
dozen
maybe next year i'll do two two dozen i
should um
so then it's gonna pass this i'm gonna
pass this information to either the web
page or iam or voice
this is actually whatever this medium is
it's going to send this information
up to the cloud now the cloud is going
to take this and it's going to process
it
it's going to say i see that the user
wants to purchase
this specific item in this case 12
yellow roses
now we have to make sure that we
actually have these roses in stock you
know
if i try to place an order and then i
pay for it and then i get a notice sorry
we're out of stock well
that's just not a good user experience
so the way this is going to work is
we'll use
various cloud services and we're
actually going to go over here and
connect
to what i'm going to call floral systems
and this is basically just going to be
our database on the back end
and it's going to show you know maybe i
have
36 yellow roses in stock i've also got
let's say 14 red tulips
and three succulents
succulents so
i've sent this information to the
webpage already as the user
now the web page is going to say all
right purchase and then 12
roses yellow roses now this is going to
send this information to the cloud
to my chat bot service provider and then
that is actually going to go out here
and check the database so i'll say 12
yellow roses is what we're looking for
and then we can see we've actually got
36 so we have plenty of roses this is
good
so now we're going to send a response
back we're going to say
yes we have more than enough roses in
stock so we can go ahead and place this
order
and the cloud is going to come back and
say yes let's place this order
and then the web page is going to come
back to me and say absolutely
you're in luck you didn't wait too long
maybe next year try to do it a little
quicker
but we're going to be able to fulfill
your order so then i'm over here the
whole time as
let's say i'm over here the floral shop
owner
and i'm just building floral
arrangements maybe i'll get a
notification kind of off to the side
but all in all the whole thing is
automated so i don't have to stop what
i'm doing to actually
take care of this and it's going to save
me a lot of time
now let's talk about the benefits of you
know why would we want to use a chat bot
i mean it is it is nice to have that
human interaction whenever you're
dealing with your customers but
i think probably the number one reason
that someone may want to use a chat bot
is to save time and what i mean by that
is
you know not only are you saving time
when it comes to
like interacting with your customers and
getting someone to place an order
but again you're leaving time off to the
side for you to
go and you know maybe you've got to do
some bookkeeping
you've got to put these floral
arrangements together whatever it is
it's going to save you hours and hours
over the course of
even just a month
two simplicity
chat plots believe it or not are
surprisingly simple to build
you don't have to know how to write any
code in most cases
if you want to do more in-depth
integrations you might need to know some
code
but for the most part it's just natural
language based
you could say hey chatbot i want you to
tell users that i'm open
monday through friday 9 am to 6 pm and
it's going to be able to relay that
information without having to know any
python or javascript or anything like
that
lastly time to launch
so what that means is that it does not
take a lot of time to build a chatbot
like i said earlier you don't have to
know any code and since it's cloud-based
you don't have to build up any of the
underlying infrastructure
from the time you start building the
chat bot to the time it's completed
could be as quick as
one hour and so these are some of the
reasons that
you may want to build a chatbot for your
business so
i hope this helped explain what a
chatbot is
how it works and why you may want to use
it thank you for watching
if you have questions please drop us a
line below if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe
and don't forget you can grow your
skills and earn a badge by creating your
own chat bot
by clicking the link below